I'm going
good time
I'm the wall
Oh
hey wastelanders thanks for coming back
to the welcoming green glow of
gamespot's fallout mod of the week this
week we're getting tachy with some tools
of the trade to build our very own
portable turrets featuring 12 turrets in
total the standard vanilla ones as well
as five new ones exclusive to the mod
this mod created by Sean M's 1991 allows
you to craft a variety of defensive
century nests to take with you on your
travels head to your nearest chemistry
bents to craft your new toys once
crafted they'll be added to your
inventory and work the same way that
mines do equip them throw them out in
front of you and watch your new minigun
pop up and immediately start reading
rate of scum you will need to have
certain perks to craft the entire range
of turrets but once you've got them you
can build machine guns spotlights heavy
machineguns lasers gamma turrets plasma
turrets shotguns heavy lasers mini guns
missiles and even the fat man turret use
with extreme caution these stationary
weapons will require ammunition so don't
think you can just set them and forget
them for an easy win they'll also need
some upkeep if they take enough damage
from anyone foolish enough to get on
business end of one you'll have to use
repair kit to get it back to working
order when combat dies down don't
abandon your new weapon out of the field
with its own interaction menus you can
pick up reload and repair your turrets
before setting out again using these
fixed guns does make some of the fights
feel a little imbalanced although they
do chew through a fair chunk of your
ammo reserves also they're super heavy
so don't expect to carry a bunch of them
through the wasteland that being said it
is quite satisfying making automated
machines do the dirty work for you my
favorite way to use them as de sep 20 3
in a choke point and then have
deathclaws or ghouls chase me into a
deadly trap if you've used this model or
have any suggestions for it then we
would love to hear them so make sure you
leave them in the comments section below
or tweet the mass using the hashtag GS
fallout I've been Dave your guide to the
wasteland and you can find me on Twitter
at a regular Dave and until next week
when we have another episode add another
mod stay safe out there wasteland ax